One idea that's very common in our culture is that poverty is caused by lack of
money.
And that's a really stupid idea because money is very difficult to handle.
I had clients who were drug addicts and the worst possible thing that could
happen to them was that they got some money.
They're just done.
First of all,
you know,
they were hanging around with people who were little on the sociopathic side.
And so,
especially if they weren't that bright and couldn't defend themselves very well,
as soon as they got the money while it was off to the bar with all the friends
and you know,
one guy I remember in particular,
you know,
every time you go out as his disability check,
he was gone for five days,
usually found them in a ditch,
you know,
cause he just go to the bar,
spend every sandy had on alcohol and cocaine and wake up in a ditch,
three quarters dead,
uh,
eventually completely dead.
And you know,
then he was ashamed and horrified and repentant and he'd straighten himself out
again.
And then that was all well and good until as long as he was broke until the next
check showed up and then bang the same thing.